good morning everyone thank you so much
for joining me this morning
um yeah so I thought maybe we'd talk
about something a little different today
or this morning
um you may know that you we are able to
be data scientists for about 15 years
now that's not such a long time
and so I thought I'd start by asking you
how many of you are have been or aspire
to work in a data team
not bad
um are you working with are you not in
data but work with people in data teams
yeah
um if you're haven't raised your rent
and yet are you working in a company
that has a data team
all right so it looks like we got the
majority
and
um you may have heard this but back in
2012 we were all told the data scientist
is the sexiest job of the 21st century
um
um yeah so and it was later reviewed and
Revisited by the same authors of that
article
um in 2022 wondering is it still the
sexiest job of the 21st century
um also in 2019
um the chief decision scientist at
Google wrote a post about how data
scientists actually the sexiest job of
the 22nd century
um so
it looks like we have a good outlook
right though that article was kind of
critical of where we are right now
um it seems like almost everyone maybe
I'm biased because I work in data so it
seems to me like almost everyone wants
to build an ml products offer AI
services or be a data scientist
and maybe recently you've sensed
something
um
because
this field while it's already 15 years
old is constantly changing
this is the last year Google Search
terms worldwide
and we've already heard a lot at this
event about GPT about large language
models and for those of us who have been
working in data for the past 15 years it
might might seem like an endless game of
catch
and really managing new and rapidly
changing business functions is not easy
um business function is a very business
term so if you're not in management let
me take a moment to explain it but in
general it's just
um a term describing an area of ongoing
operations that needs management and
lots of us are managed uh maybe all of
you if you're not independent
um we'll talk about about this a bit
more later
for now you can think of it as a
department or team that performs certain
tasks that other teams don't perform so
the business as a whole stays
operational or functional
um and it is sometimes hard for us to
accept that we would be it isn't hard
for us to accept as a business that we
would be better off if a lawyer wrote
our business contracts or agreement
we also it took some time but I think a
lot of places have already come to
understand that a designer's opinion
about the brand is more important than
the executives team's favorite colors
we can clearly but can we clearly draw
the line between data science
engineering products and services
are we even supposed to and are do we
have aligned expectations on these
things and how we make decisions about
them in an organization
so for today I want to talk to you about
three things and this will not be
specific points it will be more of a
ongoing rambling as I move between them
um so we'll start with what is
management and build some shared
understanding uh we'll talk about the
challenges we're facing
um and hopefully at the end we'll see
that there's still some positive outlook
for us all
so what is data teams management
no data team exists in a vacuum we can
talk about data scientists separately
from data engineering product teams bi
business objectives all the rest which
is why in preparation for this I also
spoke to 20 odd people working very
different roles from each other and
different seniority levels and trying to
get a bit more of a perspective about
what is it we're doing and how are we
achieving things or not
um also the data function is not a
snowflake a unicorn or a butterfly a lot
of our management challenges are common
to other functions business domains and
so on we have a lot to learn from them
and we could possibly also discuss our
issues together
management is a very broad domain
moreover
um so I would like to ask you maybe
raise your hand if you think you can
come up with a tweet length definition
of management
not a lot of takers
um mine is this it's essentially about
how we organize to achieve goals
so when I mean organized here since as
an organizer I organize a lot of things
I'm here I mean how do we make
arrangements and trade-offs
you may have heard this isn't a New
Concept about the three PS of management
and I know there are a lot of different
ones there's also versions with four and
five there's many many variations on
this I do think that the original is
kind of a tried and true framework and a
useful Baseline so in case you haven't
heard it before I'll try to also use
this as a thread throughout the rest of
my talk it's people processes and
platforms
and even in the emerging field of AI
managers can think about their work with
the three PS We lead and Empower people
they have motivations interests skills
Ambitions we need to collaborate with
other people in the organization culture
is key to people
um sometimes
after people start joining a founding
team of a small organization processes
will start to emerge and we will
eventually start to even dictate how
those should change we're trying to
coordinate structure and organize work
among those people and their peers
and along the way throughout either on
purpose or not folks working in a
specific domain will make Countess
decisions about platforms skills and
tools that they want to build use and so
on from using python as your programming
language to anything else about your
stack or infrastructure or what it is
you're building
I think the key verbs here are lead and
organize and managers don't make
decisions by themselves they balance
trade-offs
a lot of our work here as managers is
similar to other domains as if I talking
about meta management level if you
generalize management as a business
function by itself a lot of things seem
similar and the Crux is in the details
some of our challenges as data teams as
managers are similar but specific and my
goal today is to get into these
specifics and hopefully when I run out
of time maybe with some food for thought
and further ideas for discussion outside
so
um some managers I want to point out are
already doing really great work and
sharing their know-how
um I really recommend that you check
sheer's talk from last year at this
conference about processes that she and
her colleagues set up
um one moment let me grab some water
and
I'm not going to tell you today about
how I solved for the three p's at a
specific company
I am going to share I think there are
other examples that can inspire you but
at the end of the day every data team
we'll need to manage their own way we do
see some patterns and overarching themes
across organization if you talk to 20
plus people like I just did
um so how are we actually managing
um I think management from a brief look
at past schedules of this very
conference and that means it's also on
me
is one of the least discussed topics at
Pi data events we often talk about the
third P about platforms we hardly at all
talk about people and processes and so
I'm not going to talk about platforms
this morning
um so let me get into my first problem
what does it even mean to be a data
scientist
um we talked about the sexy title in the
beginning we're all hyped up for this uh
but let me let me ask you this can you
raise your hand if you can come up with
a tweet left tweak length definition for
the role data scientist and then keep
your hand raised if you can
any definition
not that many
uh keep those hands up for a moment
would you please only lower your hand if
you think that definition is possibly
unique to your organization
or is it overall the same
so
it seems
um that we have a lot of titles out
there and even the single title data
scientists that started us on this
journey
um is hard to Define only this morning I
was browsing LinkedIn as I do and I saw
a new title that I've never seen before
which the author of the post claims
should now be all the rage and we should
all be hiring for data translators I'm
not sure how many of you will ever work
with data translators I'm not saying
it's not relevant or valid and it
sounded like a really interesting take
but we have so many titles this is the
result of just a quick samplings of jobs
that were posted on LinkedIn of
so-called data scientist jobs some of
these require several several years of
experience in the description in data
strategy and governance and data
products and data architecture and data
science preferably with DBT which by the
way exists I think only from 2021 so I'm
not sure how you could have so many
years of experience Beyond too
um I've started calling this
the zoo of titles
um
my problem here isn't that we have so
many roles that might actually be a good
thing
um but it is very hard for us to
understand what these titles are we
don't have a shared language and these
job descriptions we don't really know
what they stand for even experienced
data folks have told me that they are
dreading if next they will be looking
for a job or want to change because the
job market is just so confusing your own
title might not be meaningful for your
next role because some data scientists
are mostly doing data engineering or
data analytics some data Engineers or
data and analysts are mostly doing data
science or data engineering some
software Engineers are doing machine
learning engineering and even all of
those things which are relatively common
are not the same in different
organizations
why is this unique data scientists lots
of people want a developer and don't
know what developer they need lots of
people want a designer I don't know what
kind of designer they need as well our
lawyer as I mentioned before
the issue here is that not only do we
not have a shared language within the
field but also outside of our domain we
don't have good idea folks don't have a
good idea about the new one says and
these differences between the roles or
the actions or the processes that we
need to achieve or the platforms that we
use
more often than not I see folks that um
accept if not understand that they
should be getting someone who
understands programming to build a
programming team and maybe they actually
need a team rather than one person
because several things need to be done
in order to achieve a goal but as a
product or service research and
development project data science and
data teams in general are as varied a
domain as any other Dev team or product
team building something that other
people use requires Discovery ux
architecture development QA test
automation integration
so far so similar
but when we ship a product or a solution
for things that are not data driven
things work differently than for things
that are data driven what do I mean by
that most of our Solutions are
deterministic in nature and classic
engineering and even if things are not
deterministic they are well captured by
a set of heuristics otherwise you don't
need any data folks
and of course we often solve for humans
so it's not necessarily easy to do but
we can still Define a solution or arrive
at one after some process and we might
even rely on it for some time there are
products and services out there that
have not changed significantly for many
years that we use
um but in data teams that's not the case
whether it's data analytics the design
and experiment and evaluate cause and
effect whether it's data science where
they Model A solution
um where occurrences can be perfectly
predicted build that model all of this
is inherently probable
um and
um
these drifts in data that can develop
over time errors in experiment design
all of these issues they take time to
figure out to discover
and it is going to require a lot more
maintenance work for any data product or
service
um
and potentially higher effort on
monitoring analysis and continuous
delivery then non-data-driven products
and services
and that means that potentially you
might need a bigger team and not a
single person
it is also often managed differently I
see many times folks from sea level to
product managers to Engineers that are
thinking or deciding that they need a
data scientist an analyst a data
engineer often singular
um really what they need is a team maybe
several teams a department and possibly
to listen to that person who understand
those nuances
um and that do in the domain really well
and more often than not um data manager
isn't sufficiently empowered in the
organization whether that is budget or
folks listening to them because there's
just so much other information out there
this um
is really odd to me because this is a
department that often quantifies the
business success and progress so I
really hope that more people will be
investing more and having larger data
departments
but why is this happening to us why are
we just because we're so young is it
just because it's only 15 years
the problem is often about unrealistic
expectations and we help Drive the hype
so it's a little bit on us and why can't
we have better expectations of what we
can and can't do in our field after 15
years
well it depends
um sometimes it is the hype there are
folks who want to be involved and make
decisions in AI because it's cool it's
trending I see so many Executives
posting this right now about large
language models um some folks are
rushing to data science and machine
learning
um to analytics
um because
um they want to have the people or the
product before they even put in data
Engineering in place
um
sometimes it's misestimation we said if
folks don't know the Nuance as well
misplanning maybe they want to get a lot
fast but they're often relying on what
they understand and Building
deterministic Things and so they don't
necessarily estimate the time and budget
reasonably so either before they hire
the right people or even after we all
know that estimating how long our
project takes or how risky they are is
hard we ourselves can also take it make
a mistakes and get it wrong
there's also a lot of services out there
that and tools that promise
DIY or do-it-yourself Solutions that's
great it's empowering but it can be
confusing for people who don't do this
work or have never done this work
themselves to understand their limits
and why we can't rely on them by
ourselves or go faster
and like I mentioned before there's the
zoo
it makes hiring really hard it makes
finding the right people hard it makes
developing people and keeping them
keeping Talent really really hard
um and you can probably get a bunch more
answers to this question from talking to
other folks around here and their own
personal experience
now this title zoo that I'm keep
mentioning is a symptom but it also has
adverse effects Beyond hiring
one of the most common theme that I've
been hearing about in my conversations
are issues with job satisfaction and
career development and data teams I
think I could talk just on this for
hours so I wanted to focus for you on
one point that kept coming up in my
conversations
and that is the topic of generalist
versus specialist
um we can for some folks it can be very
obvious very natural for you to make a
decision or maybe it doesn't even feel
like a decision about whether you as an
individual want to be a generalist or
Specialist or where you want to make a
switch between those at a certain time
but in a new and rapidly developing
domain there's also a lot of push and
pull in many different direction at once
and if you're not confident and what is
right for you which is common then every
time you open your professional digital
media source of choice they seem to be a
hundred new directions you can go in 100
new platforms and tools you should have
already mastered and it's really hard to
keep up with
and generalizing I think and have heard
um that it will be great for you and
your career in both small and large
companies you will be able to
collaborate and understand business
needs Solutions across the whole data
stack which is great but more and more
as we try to solve for our title zoo we
are trying to narrowly Define people
like a data translator and we're trying
to create Specialists and we want ml Ops
rather than an ml Ops engineer rather
than an ml engineer we want a machine
learning data scientist rather than a
machine learning researcher we want to
have someone specifically to do QA
someone specifically to do data
engineering with isn't it within a data
science team we have seen all of these
Trends also in engineering and design so
please remember if you're an individual
contributor if you're a manager the
generalists are always helpful and they
many great careers come from lateral
moves but data folks are also curious
beings they like to learn to apply to
make measurable impact and don't try to
create too rigid paths for personal
development as managers try to listen
and offer as much flexibility and
support as you can because working in
such a fast changing a new field is
really hard on the individuals
themselves
and I keep talking about the individuals
but this also applied to us as managers
as leads
there are a lot of managers and have
hearing this directly formed them but
also for folks who are talking about how
they are managed that are wearing many
many hats they are your people manager
your technically they are your product
manager and maybe even a few other
things we need to consider the variety
of management roles and hats that we
have just as much as a Dev team can has
several different managers that managing
people and domains and Technical
expertise it's time for our data teams
to do that as well and of course this
might not work for every organization
but just consider if maybe one of the
reasons your manager isn't working so
well is because we're asking too much of
them to
another topic that comes up a lot is
data consumers and data generators and
how well do we work together
this is also how we differ sometimes
from other development teams that we
don't necessarily own end to end
everything
often we work with data that's being
generated in marketing team and Finance
in engineering teams and so on and here
there's a saying from a very famous
Management
[Music]
Consultant from from a while back that
says that culture eats strategy from
breakfast
and I think that here more than you need
a process you need to work well with
people
um so Engineers marketing all of these
folks all of these departments whether
it's within your team or across your
data teams
um if the data team itself or the
individuals are not invested in data
quality in the solutions and in getting
to Solutions and results together with
the data generators it's going to be
very hard to achieve anything at all if
someone analyzed their own a b tests and
always uses teeth tests by themselves
because that's what they know or an
automated tool they're not going to have
great results if they haven't
collaborated or the data analyst if
someone else is able to as a developer
and doesn't write tests for their
tracking and suddenly we have gaps in
our in data that is critical for a model
then because they find tracking work to
be boring or unimportant or just why do
we need to test for that then that's a
problem
and there are also Engineers who are
trying to work on machine learning
products on their own which is great but
maybe coordinate at least with the data
team who is also doing similar work all
of these are the same as having you
write your own
hiring contracts even though you hired a
lawyer to do that or designing your own
product based on your personal
preferences and we make these mistakes a
lot they happen
um one other point that comes up is that
a lot of folks are like we reorged again
and I every time someone comes and tells
me oh yeah we ordered I'm like celebrate
that that's great this should happen
this is a natural process of managing
organizations
um your team should it be embedded
should it be centralized should it be
hybrid how many teams should you have
um do you need a data platform team on
its own to service the other teams
there's a lot of best practices here
um but you always have to adjust for
your current situation these changes and
making these changes over time is
valuable timing them getting the right
buy-in is hard and that's what sometimes
makes managing teams at all in general
hard but the truth is that our
organizations maturity scale the sense
of urgency psychological safety overall
and specifically for data teams it's
just too much to discuss in a couple of
slides so so I'm gonna save this for a
future presentation or maybe one of you
will
one more thing
so far a lot of this is relevant for
people who are working with data folks
but
we all have a part in this
some of the most important things that
we need to figure out as folks who are
working in data teams is that through
all of the hype all the excitement
um you also need to own some hard truths
you are expensive and you need to
deliver value and it's hard to deliver
value as I said before sometimes we get
things wrong
but what is sometimes most important to
you or seems crucial to you if you think
you're at odds with your manager or with
your organization you need to understand
that you want to be at a place where you
are not managed as a data team strictly
as a cost center you need to be very
mindful of return or investment or Roi
for your role and for your team
you need to be very mindful of how data
teams overall produce business value how
efficient you are and how good your
communication skills are
these things will take time when you
start you focus on your skills that have
to do with platforms and tools but you
need to remember that you can't indulge
too much in the things that brought you
to the role and you need to develop also
things that will make you successful and
make your whole team and Department
successful
you will be managed and supported in
making trade-offs should I get into a
new thing should we keep trying to do
exploratory analysis or should we just
drop this and try to do something else
or decide that actually we're not going
to be modeling for the next quarter
um I want to encourage all of you to
think of exploratory phases of data
science models as Discovery faces for
products in general
you can't accept that another product
team will be in discovery mode for six
months or more but we see this very
often with data teams
um some of you maybe are already in a
large organization with high maturity
are moving faster but there are folks
and also folks who are coming into our
field who were not trained for the pace
and urgency of business
and I think it's really important that
you should know how much your team
made profit or lost for your company how
much risk you are creating or are saving
with your work
and yeah that also means you should care
about your code quality your test
packagings slas Ops everything if you're
building tools that or products that
other people use you need to be
professional about it and you can't just
not want to
um
or worry about how when or other people
see your code or how delicate it is
so
the wonderful culture of collaboration
and again this is where culture is key
will really help you here
instead of worrying about how wrong
everything is or how hard it is to do
things you should come up with ways for
you to identify with whom and in which
project you can get things done
collaborate and Edge things forward we
won't get everything done right all of
the time and so we just need to think
about how do we progress and make data
as a business function more effective
I did this skip one thing that came up a
lot in my preparation but I don't think
that's unique to data teams I do think
it's a it's an important topic
managers really need to care care about
people management this is crucial how we
feel at work how we show up folks if you
are managers please prioritize people
management and developing those skills
spending time with individuals helping
individuals resolve issues working on
feedback culture your people management
skill set as a people manager is crucial
and
that's all I have to say about that
[Applause]
so what can we learn from all of this
um it sounds like I've been whining and
grumping here for a while is there
anything actionable is there anything we
can take I think a lot of this is Food
For Thought and discussion
um management isn't something and maybe
that's why we don't talk about it often
it's not something you can just pick up
learn do and get a check mark that it
was merged and everything works
um
one thing I hope you take away from this
is that assigning data roles is hard our
job market is a mess there's a lot of
overlaps between roles and that's
because we're not cats we're not happy
in boxes
um
what you can do is try to ensure Clarity
in each project
discuss regularly with individuals to
make sure that they know who's
responsible who has ownership what tasks
are relevant for each case and coaching
whether by a manager or by or different
roles coaching each other supporting
each other learning as few things not so
that they can do each other's roles but
so they develop an understanding of how
they can collaborate better so yeah like
I said assigning data roles is hard
that said assured understanding and
definitions are ready are going to be
vital for our work that is across data
roles across teams working with other
domains we need to really make sure that
we are good collaborator in a business
collaborators in a business environment
um if we are sitting there complaining
that we weren't involved early enough
what can we do to make sure that there's
a process that it has someone from the
data team involved early enough
and for that I really recommend to
Cheers talk again
code quality is your friend I didn't
talk about this at length but I really
think this is valuable and it also has
to do with collaboration
have all your work in the shared repo do
code reviews don't be afraid of showing
or changing your code the more people
know it the more safe you will feel and
taking a sick sick day taking a break
and so on not everything should be on
you this is a team sport
also and I think this is really
important we're all learning here one of
the worst things you can do for a
culture and a data team and maybe in
general is create a space where being
wrong is bad we deal with uncertainty
that's our work we try things out dare I
say experiment there's no blueprints for
how to do all the things
culture really affects people in this
and the requirement and we need to also
realize that going back to how both the
job market works but also how our teams
work being wrong is really really not
being afraid of being wrong or not
thinking of it of being as being wrong
is really important we're seeing that
the requirements for junior positions
are rising as their salaries are
um
becoming lower and we're seeing more
competition for jobs in our field
overall at the same time seniors folks
who have been here for 10 to 15 years
and leads sometimes can feel unsafe to
show that there's something they can't
to do because it's a new thing or
they're out of practice and something
that they used to be good at really
creating a safe curious work culture
um is really what we should be doing and
I want to just encourage all of you once
again to find ways to hire Juniors and
develop them because I think we really
are at a very tough place with our field
and focusing all of the what I'm
currently seeing quite a lot is that a
lot of the job ads are just everybody
just wants a senior so think about how a
junior could write tests for you and
make your code better or any other tasks
that you think someone could learn from
and develop and grow within your team
and I also want to take a moment to
thank all the people who helped me to
get here to help me to prepare this talk
help me throughout my career I
couldn't be here by myself I couldn't do
this I couldn't talk about all of these
things I am not an expert but I am
someone who enjoys learning from others
and I am constantly supported in this
and I'm constantly getting feedback
myself and I've been treated with so
much kindness and generosity in our
community I hope you all have the same
in your careers and please stay in touch
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much Noah so let me just
sit and I read questions we have slido
many questions came in already
yeah I'm going to read them too
oh
second so
more questions coming in okay the most
popular one from Alina Alina asks which
metrics would you recommend to use
measuring data team performance and
contribution to business growth yeah I
think that is a very valuable question I
often talk to other managers about this
unfortunately again we're going to have
to say it depends it depends on what
your data team is working on and how
they're delivering value to the business
um and then the question is how best Can
you capture it I would want to recommend
we tend to like having everything
precise and super data driven it's okay
to use qualitative measures
just so you know
next question what do you think of a
specific data team versus distributed
data focused engineers in all different
teams
great so like I said I think we can do a
whole talk about this
um I it's a favorite topic of mine I
think it has a lot to do with how big
your organization is and the maturity
like I said before
um and very very kind of Cliff Notes
version is in a very small startup I
would expect folks to be more embedded
as the company grows I expect them to
centralize to try to build expertise
and and make sure that they really are
improving how it is they work and then
as they grow further than that they
could probably move to a hybrid where
there's
some Foundation teams or share teams
that build expertise and tools and some
that folks that are embedded and can
work really directly I would recommend
that you if you are in this model that
you always hire new people into the
central teams so they can learn all the
best practices and then move into
different products and service teams
thank you Alexander asks any suggestion
for how job a job candidate can verify
that HR has a proper properly understood
the role of data scientists slash
engineer to make sure you just don't end
up as an analyst that's great I wish I
wish I had the the way to like decode
all of those I'm afraid that because of
the zoo right now it will have to be in
conversation you need to come up with
some good questions to ask as early as
possible in the interview process and
you need to be critical I know it's
sometimes hard when you're on the job
market you can't wait to get a job but
it's okay for you to decide that some
jobs are not for you and try to find
what if there are specific things that
you want to do or interested in or
wondering who are the analysts what will
I be doing how will I be collaborating
with them are the things that what what
kind of tasks will you be doing if it's
not in the job description then try to
ask out and see what answers they have
for you
next question do you think there's a
difference in understanding between
engineering let and non-engineering led
organizations how should we account for
that
I'm sure there is
um I don't know how some of the things I
talked about are going to be directly
um related to that I think I've been
also in work with amazing companies that
are also their whole core was a machine
learning project and the founding team
was very technical
of course that's going to kind of have
an impact but then then sometimes in
those teams because folks are so
empowered and and feel like they
understand all the details then
sometimes there are less skilled in data
analytics or they are just think they
already know everything and they're not
empowering their data teams enough so
those are kind of difficulties you might
be facing there but yeah there are going
to be differences I don't think I can
enumerate them all
next question what is the difference
between a data scientist and a data
analyst
great question uh
um I think they're going to like we
checked before you're going to find out
as many answers as there are people here
if not more
um throughout my talk I think I kind of
separated it as a little bit around
whether or not you're building
um Data Solutions that other folks will
be using potentially as a product like
other users outside of the company and
that are more likely than not to be
predictive machine learning or
classification problems or something
like that whereas an analyst usually
helps internally to make decisions we
also sometimes call our analytics teams
decision science or decision teams and
they are they're they're science or or
math skills or algorithm skills are also
going to more towards
creating visualizations or doing like I
said knowing a lot of Statistics in
order to check for causality and that's
great because if your machine learning
team doesn't know how to you know a B
test their model then maybe the animal
can come and help
this one I really love
how do you manage going from data
prototype to data product once I
presented the Prototype there was an
expectation that next week this thing
should be a product
yeah
I'm so sorry
yeah I mean I don't know ask them if
they think engineering can take a
product from a prototype to uh to a
full-fledged uh product the next day and
if they still say that then go back and
say well but what I do is probabilistic
so it's a bit harder it's not like I can
just take this it will work for any case
we now need to adjust I hope that helps
yeah
thank you it's I'm combining a few
questions because you're really similar
um they're also about management and
skills so I'm just going to read three
of them my management has no experience
with it what books talks conferences
conferences really do you recommend for
them to understand the data team also as
a manager do you have any guidelines
when it's the best to develop an
internal capability or to Outsource it
and there was one more questions how
about enabling yeah do you have any tips
for juniors to overcome this fear doing
things wrong or sharing code it's more
like skill related questions let's go
back this a lot so the first one was uh
about
lacking data literacy yes
so there's a lot of devastated teams
need to accomplish and there were teams
that I was that one of our main things
for a quarter or two
or Toyota literacy in the organization
help be a part of the solution like I
said edging things forward
um and in doing that try to not tell
people you don't know but try to come up
with what do you know why would you like
to use it how could I be of help so here
like actually using interview skills ux
research skills would be really useful
for your team as you're developing the
skill set overall it's also not all on
you and if you really think that
organization isn't going to manage a
data team well you can go to another
organization
very good
um the second one was about Outsourcing
yeah as a manager do you have any
guidelines one it's best to develop an
internal capability
uh or Outsourcing it so I think uh
there's two things uh if it's going to
be a core thing of your product team
service for a long time then developing
it in-house is going to be great for you
wasting in your future
um but if there's something where you
it's not it's not going to be core or
maybe you already have someone in your
team that wants to learn this but needs
support
um then maybe then going to a consultant
or an expert to kind of help speed you
up from where you are but you do think
you already have some of the skill sets
that are required that might be a way to
think about it but this is so Broad and
has so many different cases that it
would depend
oh very good I see you're speeding up we
have three minutes through a coffee
break and we have definitely more
questions than for three minutes how
many questions do you want to take I
mean until the coffee break let's do
that
I think you're around you're happy to
and get serious definitely questions
just well but there was a third one that
you that I have yes this is the third
one do you have any tips for juniors to
overcome this fear of doing things wrong
or sharing code I mean first I mean I
hope you're on an environment that's
supportive I can't control for your
environment but the one thing I can tell
you is that I mistake make mistakes all
the time everybody I know does we're all
learning and you don't even know if
maybe like I said your leads your
seniors you're working with are also
have the same concern so maybe talk
about it hopefully you have
psychological safety and you can all
figure it out together
next question from Ikea when trip Ryan
transitioning from a developer to a
manager what were the biggest challenges
for you
so
um
I think one of the biggest challenges
was being alone uh as soon as you become
a manager and I've recorded a podcast
about why you shouldn't be a manager
um
that one of the hardest things for me
personally is that you go from being a
part of the team that to being while
you're a part of the team but in a very
different way there are certain certain
things you can't discuss there are
certain things that people will stop
discussing with you and while you can
talk to other management peers you're
they're never going to be in your team
so that's for me one of the hardest
things
hmm
why the focus on role naming isn't it
more important what the required skills
and experiences are I agree I meant the
zoo titles but it's actually the job
description title let's let's make this
a broader problem
do you have General recommendations
hiring strategies for data scientists
given that the field is too broad
um hiring is really hard not just in
data teams in general hiring is a very
very hard process and task to do well
um I guess my biggest tip for this is
expect to fail expect to get things
wrong
um because it's it's not always going to
be easy and try to have a conversation
try to engage with folks and talk to
them about what they're interested in
about what you need and not just check
for skills but really talk to them and
check for
um for will they fit the role as far as
motivation interests the tasks and so on
questions I'm sorry
um we are already in the coffee break
but this is the last question how to
balance the time between skill building
and doing Deployable work
great question
um I think that's hard as well what I've
heard and I think sheer mentioned it
last year in her talk as well is that it
might be better to not do a certain
percent of your time
um that I also always found both as a
contributor as a manager to be really
hard to do but try to Define periods of
like after you've shipped something give
someone from the shipping team a month
to go and do and work on something else
so like take all of that 10 time and
Munch it all together and rotate there
we also when I was working a king we had
a kind of a team where people could
rotate in and out too that did more like
off-topic things so maybe those are two
approaches that could help
thank you so much
yeah
[Music]